was your full title how do they address
you hi I'm Dave from boyinaband and
today I'm here with the professor dr.
Martin Polyakov CBE FRS ba ma PhD DSC SC
d fic C can fi chem II see it was
exactly what I was used to you know
being a musician I totally have a
horrendous amount of explosions going on
all over the place it didn't sound that
different to what I was used to being a
dubstep producer but it certainly looked
a bit different and there were a lot
more signs saying don't touch and you
might die and things like that which was
a lot of fun it was very warm very warm
and colorful and I think I singed some
of this the whole time I was just
constantly thinking this sound is
awesome every now and again I just hear
a sound that was just incredible and so
many of these chemistry experiments make
these tonal sounds which are so
interesting for this kind of music and
they can be layered up very very
effectively to make something that's
really interesting to listen to one of
my favorite moments was when we did the
barking dog' experiment with the really
large tube and it was it Neil told me
that is going to be loud I was like oh
I'm a music video I've been onstage I
know what loud is I didn't know what
loud was as lair man that was loud yes
it was that first of all had to took all
50 different files from all the things
we recorded onto the computer listened
through them all named them all to the
random hissing noise organized them into
percussion tonal stuff effects so kind
of like woosh e sounds and things like
that and just random noises that didn't
really seem to fit anywhere hammer thing
centrifuge vacuum drain and Bunsen
barking dog firework he pops firework he
pops I wanted to try and make it
interesting
the start and I thought showing one of
these experiments being compiled and
then exploding would be a great initial
start to it and one of the coolest ones
was where the ice was set on fire which
was not something I thought physically
possible before this was just quite cold
feel quite educated now and so yes it
made a really satisfying boom sound
right at the start this one here and
then the crackles started to sound a bit
rhythmic when I looped them and I really
quite liked it sound a bit like a hi-hat
on a drum kit
[Music]
well for this one there was a lot more
percussion than there were tonal sounds
so I had to be quite careful and I
figured rather than trying to aim for
something that was hugely melodic I just
focused on what I had and make it more
about the rhythms and the percussion so
I started by just building up four
separate beats throughout the song
there's the first one which I did with
the the fire is the kick drum I show you
that line and then I found this
incredible sound when the the bung in
this big tube was popped off by the gas
inside it which sounded like if you're
an electronic music head there's
something called an 808 kick drum which
is a very old synthesizer and it sounded
so much like that like an authentic
synthesized kick drum it came across
quite like this that sound there even
has that at the top just like a hi-hat
[Music]
incredible so then I just dropped into
that like I just want to rap over it now
worked out so nicely then we quickly
took tin a bit of a chemical jar which I
thought that's a just tapping some
chemicals on the side there and then
dropped in
finally to the big drop and that was
made by two separate devices popping I
can't remember quite the guy I should
have probably done more remembering of
what the science was but they had to
dislike the different tonal qualities
one came across as a kick drum with a
bit of a bassy sound and the other one
was more of a snare this is 100% the
sounds I recorded which I'm really
really pleased with I didn't know
whether I'd have to start layering it up
but everything was so basic and
interesting that it really really worked
I'm so happy that that happened it's
more authentic that way I wanted to have
a big kind of culmination at the end
where it started to bring in all the
different elements that we've got
throughout the song so it kind of builds
goes a bit crazy with the rhythms and
then and then crash out to one of the
more colorful experiments again I was
trying to think about the visuals as
well because I thought this would be a
nice nice one to really show off what
can be done with these experiments I
will create the song and then I will
pass it over to Adam who will then do
the visual aspect of it so we'll have a
discussion and figure out what we want
to do and then he'll do it and I'll go
back to another song I generally leave
Dave to do his thing and just go on with
it and and yeah well for this project
we've we've actually we've got a hard
drive which both of the computers share
so we're able to just dump stuff on the
hard drive on one computer then take it
off on the other computer so that we can
sort of both send each other edits and
things on the fly it's very very quick
for this project he where he sent me
over the song so I've got the four song
together but he also sent me each
individual stem so each sound like it
just the foot picks a sound and for the
whole song he renders out the song with
just that sound playing this half of the
screen is audio tracks this is the video
that I've got end of the minute this is
say this is one which is filling the
tube and as you can see there's nothing
at the start of the song there but then
at the end we can hear that it's just
that sound there's nothing else playing
on this lay here we've got the the
fireworks sound which is this this
effect over here and then when you see
this sound happen on the audio channel
you know that the up here the
corresponding video channel has to put
the the clip in the right place so that
when you play together hopefully a lot
of fun it's quite different to a lot of
stuff we do but it's interesting because
these sort of you working with loads of
different streams of video at the same
time and you have to pull it all
together and make it coherent it'll be
fun
maybe I don't know I don't wanna make
any promises I'm not making promises and
if it's not good I'm not going to upload
it but if it's not good I'm also not
going to upload this so it doesn't
matter yeah all right
it will also be interested to see what
people think of your production and I
wish you great success thank you and I
hope I hope that it will give people a
new view of chemistry